alors messieurs le rapporteur cher
collègue monsieur le ministre je serai
au parlement comme je l ai été pour tous
les autres textes qui portent sur le zoo
sanitaire on associe énormément le
parlement la démocratie cote avez vous
déclaré le 22 décembre dans une célèbre
matinale si je suis désolé de n'avoir
pas remarqué votre présence toutes les
fois précédentes
je suis ravi de vous voir ce jour ce
texte n'aura pas d'effets sur les vagues
en cours sur la désorganisation de la
société sur le drap d'une école m
l'ouver coûte que coûte au lieu d'être
sécurisée coûte que coûte ce texte ne
répond pas à une nouvelle urgence
sanitaire ce texte n'est pas destiné à
freiner la propagation du virus ce n'est
pas son objet les écoles sont en
souffrance votre doctrine de bâtir des
écoles ouvertes se doit d'évoluer vers
le métier dans de bonnes conditions
ffp2 pour les professeurs détecteur de
co2 quand même si vous affirmer qu'on
peut à errer sans les détecteurs c'est
plus simple de respecter les limitations
de vitesse quand on est un conteur
agir maintenant dans une phase explosive
de contamination est au mieux peu
efficace pourtant tous les signes
étaient là dès fin novembre
dès la montée du delta et avec les
premières informations sur au micro rien
n'a été fait à ce moment là malgré
l'avis du conseil scientifique
mais comme souvent depuis février
dernier le gouvernement cherche à
réfléchir seul jusqu'au dernier moment
les conseils de défense ou secret se
multiplient et les avis comme le dernier
du hcsp sur les ffp2 ne sont accessibles
que selon votre calendrier la droite
sénatoriale roumègue mais vend toujours
en essayant d'encadrer périmètre est dur
et nous sommes donc en état d'urgence
perpétuelle sécuritaires sanitaires et
quoi d'autre ensuite vous focaliser sur
des objectifs dérivés une lutte contre
leur confinement supérieur à la lutte
contre l'épidémie un désir de sauver
noël plus grand que celui de sauver
notre système hospitalier
derrière vos choix d' équilibre il y as
au mieux un attentisme optimiste au pire
très critiquable calculs politiciens
revenons au pass sanitaire puis
vaccinale à cette obligation vaccinale
déguisés et pourtant non obligatoire je
vous rappelle que d'autres groupes
écologistes a alerté dès le début est
régulièrement sur le risque d'une
généralisation trop importante de se
passe à la fois dans le temps mais aussi
dans son périmètre dans les activités où
les lieux qu'ils toucheraient ou même
l'adie ou quand ce qui entraînerait sa
mise en oeuvre le présent renforce nos
alertes et nous laisse augurer d'une
société de contrôle permanent camouflé
par des état d'urgence successifs et
récurrent donc nous voici devant un
texte qui prévoit trois types de passes
sanitaire invs vaccinale et vaccinales
plus ça doit être ça le pragmatisme dont
vous vous réclamez sans cesse texte qui
prévoyait en plus l'obligation du pass
vaccinale des douze ans une obligation
vaccinale déguisée des douze ans
heureusement retiré par votre commission
sous l'égide de son rapporteur que je
salue cette vision séparatistes de la
société triés par les passes successifs
nous la rejetons nous y sommes
totalement opposés se passe vaccinale
ouvre en quelque sorte l'accès à la
possibilité de transmission et de
propagation sans autre moyen contre et
alternatifs comme les tests pcr ou les
masques ffp2 je rajoute que cela laisse
à penser que pour travailler se déplacer
sortir dans des lieux publics vivre en
quelque sorte nous devons bientôt en
permanence et définitivement pour des
années nous faire vacciner plusieurs
fois par an
[Musique]